sylvain ce doit être encore plus dur
pour les familles avec ce qu'on a appris
aujourd'hui mais elle avait été prévenu
quand même avant les médias oui c'est ça
alors on peut présumer que c'est en
effet très dur que le choc est doublé
d'apprendre cette nouvelle terrible
qu'il s'agirait donc d'un geste délibéré
de la part du copilote ont pu imaginer
donc les famines était sous le choc
aujourd'hui mais c'est un difficile de
le savoir parce que on n'a aucun contact
avec les membres et amis
il ya des centaines qui sont passés ici
dans le village aujourd'hui ils sont
encadrées de près par des policiers et
gendarmes il circule dans des voitures
et des autobus ou vitres teintées on n'a
aucun accès à leur lieu de réunion ou à
leur logement
cependant oui en effet le procureur
responsable de la requête a confirmé
lors de son point de presse que les
familles et des pelles et bien été
informé de toutes ces informations
révélés par les enregistrements de la
botte de boîtes noires avant soit sa
conférence de presse il avant que le
public ne soit informé il a d'ailleurs
il s'est employé à rassurer tout le
monde en disant qu en effet à la fin de
cet enregistrement on entend des cris
revenant de du passager ce serait juste
avant l'impact au plus près
et c'est speed tenté de dire que jusqu'à
la dernière minute les passagers n'ont
pas été convoqués la catastrophe puis
cela me paraît bien revenons maintenant
à lenquête quels sont les scénarios qui
sont maintenant envisagée évidemment ça
donne une nouvelle tournure et cette
enquête
on va essayer de flea de passer de son
copilote précis de programmes qu'elles
pouvaient être ses motivations
pour l'instant on ne riait sur ce garçon
apparemment d'après ses amis
c'est à dire sur tout à fait normal
d'après les porte parole de la compagnie
aérienne il avait su
les tests psychologiques comme tous les
autres du don qu'il présentait le profil
tout à fait il
remail tout ce qu'on sait c'est que par
ses années de service comme agent corps
avant de devenir co puis la courge owens
il a dû interrompre sa formation à
quelques reprises pour des raisons
médicales ont d'abord que je serais pour
des causes de dépression mais quand même
ça remonte à il ya plusieurs années sa
dette une mycose qui jouerait solide
pour l'instant dont on bafouille sans
doute dans toutes les directions que ce
sera sûrement très très lo céline avant
qu'on sache vraiment qu'est ce qui a pu
motiver cette offre comme ce sera aussi
très tôt avant que toute opération de
récupération à la fois les dépôts et
consorts il était en montagne soit
terminée on a là aussi on est juste elle
très long et vous allez continuer de
suivre cette affaire pour nous merci
beaucoup silva